I like that to step up to the plate does
anyone have to ring the bell
like
I feel I had some school
okay well I'm very pleased to introduce
myself this is me Steve right so I guess
there were four talks this afternoon is
that right okay all right we can always
have an extra line of people that's
still up for it yeah all right so I'd
like to talk about some tools that
people use to solve non convex smooth
optimization problems so in the first
part I'll sort of give an overview of
the different algorithmic elements that
are useful in this context and a little
bit of the background and also a little
bit about what people have been doing
with this with these elements assembling
them into algorithms that you can prove
things about and the second part of the
talk I'll talk specifically about
something that we did my postdoc Clement
Laurier and myself in a paper that we
uploaded I guess three months ago about
three months ago so I'll talk about that
and what we do specifically and what
sort of guarantees we get and I actually
gave this talk or something very like
this in the Bliss seminar last week over
in ECE but I made a little perturbation
here I added some numerix in the last
few slides and the whole reason for that
was I wanted to cross Ben's boundary you
know Ben has this classification of
people that do have numerical results
some people that don't
so just by making this epsilon
perturbation of the talk I've managed to
change my classification according to
Ben yeah so I'm now in class two in
class one all right so here's our setup
we're just trying to minimize a smooth
non-contact potentially non convex
function and the goal is to find a
second order necessary point so this is
one way the gradient 0 and the Hessian
is positive semi-definite okay that's
what we're looking for is something that
nearly satisfies that so we're going to
consider mostly descent algorithms most
of the methods that have been proposed
for this problem do go downhill at every
step not all there are some exceptions
to that I'm going to assume that
everything's nice ok that
right up you've got smoothness right up
to Lipschitz continuity of the Hessian
over the set of interest okay which is a
neighborhood of this level set because
we're talking about descent methods we
only have to consider points X where the
function value is lower than at the
initial point so because we've got a
Lipschitz constant LG on the gradient l
h on the hessian right away from
taylor's theorem we can get upper bounds
on the function value at X plus P for
any X and P in this you know in this
general area so the we get this
quadratic upper bound by just going out
to one term of the Taylor series and
then bounding the quadratic term above
by LG which is sort of an upper bound on
the norm of the hessian and then we can
go at one more term in the Taylor series
and get this cubic upper bound where LH
here is a Lipschitz constant for the
hessian okay and these turned out to be
very useful in deriving algorithms
because you can get interesting
algorithms but just by replacing the
function at the current iterate x x
equals xk by one of these approximations
and then taking the minimum of that with
respect to p and using that as a
potential step okay so we're actually
going to loosen these conditions a
little bit and look for approximate
second-order necessary points that's
where the gradient the norm of the
gradient falls below some threshold
epsilon G and the Hessian has at
eigenvalues all greater than minus
epsilon H where epsilon G and epsilon H
are both small numbers okay
the end of the minus something okay and
we're looking for iteration complexities
that is we want to express how much work
do we have to do measured by the number
of iterations we need to take or
measured by some other fundamental
measure of computational workload how
much work we have to do to find points
that satisfy these properties and we'll
express those complexities in terms of
these choices of epsilon here and also
possibly in terms of the dimension of
the problem and the two Lipschitz
constants on the gradients in the
hessian okay so you'll see all of these
things showing up in these expressions
now defining the computational workload
we could measure that by figuring out
how many gradient evaluations we need to
do how many Hessian vector products we
need to apply
how many times you have to minimize a
multi-dimensional cubic something like
this you could think of that as a unit
of work how many trust region
subproblems you need to solve all of
these are different ways of you know
figuring out exactly what you have to do
and at some way to express the total
workload as a function of these how many
operations of each of these types you
need another operation we need in a lot
of these methods is some way to a
computer approximately compute the most
negative eigenvalue of the hessian so
that's another sort of fundamental
operation so a little bit of background
here of course this problems been around
in optimization forever people have
wanted to minimize smooth non convex
functions for a long time and if you
look in our book here you'll see a bunch
of things described newton coins you
gradient where you take the Newton
equations and solve them iteratively by
cg with some enhancements l-bfgs of
course is a still extremely popular
approach non-linear extensions of cons
your gradient and so on and and
traditionally an optimization would
prove results like all the accumulation
points of this method are stationary
well we might say ok if you are
converging to a second-order sufficient
point that satisfies second-order
sufficient conditions you'll converge
rapidly well they might have a stronger
guarantee that accumulation points are
second order necessary points things
like that we didn't really pay much
attention to complexity I would say very
few people are interested in that that
sort of you know nemirovsky n' and some
of the russian school but of course
that's where a lot of the action is now
people care a lot these days about
complexity and probably the modern era
of this dates to this nestra of poly yak
paper in 2006 where they proposed a
cubic regularization idea and and gave
some complexity guarantees for it and
that's spurred a lot of you know renewed
activity in the space and and and of
course this is a lot of this is driven
by what's happening in machine learning
as in so much of optimization these days
a lot of the impetus for different for
looking into different new paradigms and
analyzing algorithms is coming from
machine learning and of course there's a
there's a whole hotbed of non convex
problems in that space
deep neural networks if you do explicit
low-rank parameterizations in matrix in
tensor optimization you get non convex
problems and there's this area of robust
statistics where which is a big thing
here at berkeley with martin wayne ridin
and his collaborators where they have
non convex regularization functions so
these sorts of problems are becoming
more and more ubiquitous so there's a
lot of interest in techniques for
solving them ok so before I sort of dive
into this fairly wide-ranging set of
algorithmic tools that you might use to
assemble a method with good complexity I
want to talk about an incredibly basic
method and this takes me all of two
slides to explain and and fully analyze
which actually does pretty well it gets
within an epsilon to the minus 1/2 of
the best known complexity and it's
incredibly simple-minded algorithm okay
so I can guarantee you that if you've
got a function with the additional
assumption that is bounded below ok
that's OK in machine learning because
mostly lost functions and bounded below
by 0 so you get a lower bound for free
but I'm gonna have to assume that here
in addition to these smoothness
properties and I'm going to show that
you can find a point satisfying that
approximate second order necessary
condition that I showed a few slides ago
in order of this many iterations epsilon
0 minus 2 epsilon H to the minus 3 so
this method takes two kinds of steps
first of all if you're at a point where
the gradient is still above threshold
bigger than epsilon G you simply take a
steepest descent step and you scale it
by 1 over the Lipschitz constant of the
gradient so this is a very traditional
short step steepest descent approach
guaranteed to give descent ok so that's
what you do in that case in the case
where the Hessian is where the gradient
is flat but the Hessian has a
significantly negative eigen value that
it's a smallest eigen value is less than
minus epsilon H then you go looking for
a direction that captures that smallest
eigen value ok so you find the vector D
of norm 1 that is the eigen vector
corresponding to that smallest eigen
value and this is of course is a
symmetric matrix so it's known how to
solve this problem and you also pick the
D the eigen value can go either
direction plot
- you picked the sense that goes
downhill with respect to the gradient
what's left of the gradient which by
this point is pretty flat okay so then
I'm going to choose I'm going to choose
this step length once I've computed this
direction DK I'm going to choose alpha K
to be two times the absolute value of
this negative eigen value divided by the
Lucas constant for the Hessian all right
so now on the next slide this is the
complete analysis of that that approach
the first line here is just what happens
when you take the gradient step if you
just plug in the definition of the step
that you take otherwise you're done
because you satisfy both of these below
threshold conditions okay all right so
if you take the gradient step I'm just
gonna plug in this step here into the
into this quadratic upper bound that I
got back here I'll just plug in P equals
minus one over L G times the gradient
and I get that you get this amount of
decrease okay otherwise if you take the
negative coverage step the one with the
hessian the one that you computed from
the hessian now you use the cubic upper
bound that I had on that earlier slide
you plug in alpha K times D and you know
do some reduction and this is just the
value of alpha K here squared is a cubic
upper bound blahblah by what you end up
with is you get this much decrease okay
order of epsilon H to the minus to the
three and so given that you know that
the function is lower bounded and you
you've just proved here that you're able
to make this much progress or that much
progress depending on the kind of step
that you took your everyone make
substantial progress something bounded
away from zero so if you just divide the
gap between the initial point f of X
naught and the lower bound let's call it
f bar divide that by the amount of
progress you're making at every step you
end up with an expression for how many
steps you need okay
so you just divide the gap in the non
optimality of the function by the
minimum of these two quantities and that
gives you this complexity okay
epsilon H to the minus 3 epsilon G to
the minus 2 okay and that's it so this
is a very simple algorithm they get
improvable complexity and it's within
striking distance of the best known
results so the best known results
including the cubic regularization
method of nesterova and po act they're
able to improve this -2 here to a minus
3 over 2 okay yeah minus 3 is always
there you can sort of play with it I
will do later you can play with how you
set the values of these two things
relative to each other and get some sort
of unified down well you're gonna get
stuck at a stationary point then unless
you bring in secure that losses to it
there's no magic this is a completely
transparent that's always true for
steepest ascent yeah right that's true
via steepest descent but only if the
gradients bigger than epsilon G yeah
yeah ok ok so the rest of the talk is
about shaving off this epsilon G to the
1/2 term basically that's where that's
where the action is
ok now that's how many iterations let's
think about how much work you need to do
well if you're taking a gradient step
you just need to do a gradient
evaluation that's it if you're taking
the second-order step you have to solve
this eigenvalue problem or at least you
have to have a way of capturing the most
negative eigenvalue okay which might be
significantly more work you might have
to most naively you'd form the Hessian
and then do an order n-cubed operation
to calculate the eigen vector
decomposition or you can use power
method or land chose method or something
in fact I'm going to talk about using
randomly started land shots in this
context there are these papers in the
literature from about 25 years ago that
say that give complexities for randomly
started LAN choice in finding extreme
eigenvalues and in this particular
application if you tweak those methods
to address the problem of finding the
most negative eigenvalue you can show
that you get it with with to pretty high
accuracy to probability 1 minus Delta in
this many Hessian vector products so LG
which is ellipsis constant on the
gradient divided by epsilon H which is a
lower bound on the most
in value okay so if you if you're if
your unit of work is either a gradient
evaluation or a Hessian vector product
then you have to factor in this extra
the fact that you have to do multiple
Hessian vector products on each line
choice iteration and if you factor that
in you have an extra epsilon H to the
minus 1/2 so this power goes up from
minus 3 than my soul over to yeah
yes I'm assuming you know all that stuff
yeah yeah these these are not practical
methods yet ok so there are even an
extra leg paper and in a lot of
literature for accelerating grainy there
are adaptive methods that successively
try to estimate those constants but I'm
just going to assume here that we know
it they are okay so in the rest of the
talk I'll just talk about as I said I'll
introduce these algorithmic elements
that you can use to construct methods
that get that sort of complexity or
hopefully better and then I'll show I'll
talk about the specific method that that
we worked on ok so going back to this
lanzhou thing I'll just say a little bit
more about this it actually comes up
again so the name of the game here is
were given a symmetric matrix and what
Lin chose method does is it picks some
starting vector and then generates his
Krylov subspace by taking that starting
vector and successfully multiplying it
by a and then it looks for the vector in
that subspace that minimizes Z transpose
AZ so of course once this becomes the
entire space this will capture the
minimum eigen value or the most negative
eigen value and you can show that you
can do this very efficiently in LAN
Cho's method you get a iterative formula
that looks a lot like conjugate gradient
it's very closely related to kanjou
gradient and you know it's sort of
magically it gives you this increasingly
better approximations to the the most
negative eigenvalue okay now we don't
have to nail it exactly we can stop it
when we get you know given that we know
we're dealing with a situation where the
negative eigenvalue is below minus
epsilon h we can stop it when we get
within minus one-half epsilon h of that
and that will give a sufficiently
negative
amount of curvature to be able to
approve complexity so we don't have to
get it exactly but we have to get it to
within a tolerance of about that much
and that leads to that complexity
estimate that I showed here okay so the
same thing here we of course there's
always a chance it will fail if you if
you generate this random starting vector
and it happens to lie in the subspace of
some other eigenvalue it happens to have
no component in the sub spur in the
direction of the most negative
eigenvalue it will fail but of course a
chance of that happening are very small
so but still if you want to do a precise
analysis you have to take account of the
fact that you always you may always fail
at any given iteration things could go
pear-shaped as we say in Australia and
and you won't find by this negative
curvature direction and you'll terminate
prematurely so you have to sort of take
into account the possibility that that
might happen so how is this algorithmic
element used well we've already seen how
it's used use it to find approximate
negative curvature directions for the
Hessian okay conjugate gradient very
similar to LAN choice except that
instead of minimizing over the Krylov
subspace instead of minimizing Z
transpose AZ you're minimizing a
quadratic with possibly a linear term so
it over the same crawl of subspace so
this is what when I said that LAN choice
and CG you are closely related this is
what I meant they're really the same -
except for the presence of this extra
linear bias term and in NC G ok and
again it has a similar sort of
complexity the amount of effort you need
to get termination to a relative
accuracy of Epsilon basically to get
within epsilon of the solution the true
solution for some you know way of
measuring the error is related to the
square root of the condition number and
this is just the ratio of the largest to
the smallest eigen value of a I assume
here I'm dealing with positive definite
a ok so both the largest and smallest
eigen values are positive so how can you
possibly use this in an algorithm for
non smooth for smooth non convex
optimization you you could use CG to
solve the Newton step and in fact this
has been done for many years
Newton CG is based on writing down then
you
and then using CG to approximately
satisfy to approximately solve that that
system we also use it in our method to
solve a regularizer version of the
Newton equations where we boost the
diagonal of the Hessian by a little bit
enough to make it safely positive
definite so that we know that this is a
positive definite coefficient matrix so
I'll talk about this later on when I
talk about our method a little bit ok so
see G here's another thing accelerated
gradients something that's probably
familiar to everyone this idea that you
can take a gradient type method and buy
some extremely clever logic and
manipulation get it to improve its
complexity so straight steepest descent
has a complexity related to order Kappa
log epsilon where Kappa again is the
ratio of the largest to smallest eigen
values of the Hessian of the whatever
convex function you're trying to
minimize with acceleration you can
increase that the square root of Kappa
so how might you use that in this
context well you can't apply it directly
because we're dealing with non convex
functions here however there are
algorithms including by people in this
audience that make use of acceleration
essentially they they convex if I the
function they get an estimate on the
lower the lowest eigen value of the
Hessian and then they beef up the
function by adding that having a
quadratic based on that estimate to the
to the function f and then applying
these accelerated methods to that convex
if I'd problem ok and they build an
algorithm around that so so it can be
used in this context even though it the
original f that we're dealing with is a
non convex ok trust region again this is
a classical technique and a very
powerful one and I think one that's kind
of being rediscovered lately and people
are looking at this and you but the idea
is that you when you're working with any
sort of low order Taylor series
approximation to the function you only
trust that approximation within a
certain region so we thought yesterday
and Alexander's talk he only trusted
that of that approximation within a
certain box shape region around the
current point they defined by an
infinity norm
traditionally in optimization we
we've tended to use the 2-norm only
because this problem is quite easy to
solve this you can solve this
efficiently even when the session is
indefinite and that still comes as a
price to people because people think ok
general QP it's a hard problem
you know NP huh well it turns out you
know it's actually very easy when you've
got this bull construct it essentially
just becomes a matter of figuring out
what the Lagrange's multiplier is that
corresponds to this constraint and then
adding on the square of D onto the
objective so you just have to figure out
what the value of Rho K is which
corresponds to this value of Delta K
here yeah any QP with one quadratic
constraint can be solved yeah yeah sure
all right good right so so you know this
this is not bad I mean typically these
methods work by taking it usually within
three guesses of R okay they've actually
got a pretty accurate solution you can
you can there are specialized sort of
route finding methods for identifying R
okay so now these methods were already
known to converge the second order
necessary points okay but the
traditional analysis didn't have any
complexity associated with it as far as
I know it was a global convergence to
result but without a rate so these have
been around since the 70s in the
optimization literature and as I say
they've been rediscovered because people
realize that when you're dealing with
something like a deep learning landscape
where there's lots of saddle points
these methods can actually escape from
saddle points even if you are at a point
where the grading is actually zero
solving this problem will actually give
you a the most negative curvature
direction and you can make progress
along that direction as we've already
seen okay line search and this I
mentioning this because this is what we
use in in our algorithm but any of you
that are programmed optimization methods
which i think is probably everyone
probably have programmed backtracking
many times okay in backtracking you pick
a direction of search you pick some
initial guess about how far you want to
move along that direction
you try that guess if the function value
goes downhill
by a sufficient amount you say fine
that's good enough I'll take the step
otherwise your back track you multiply
that initial guess by some theta try
that value if that doesn't work repeat
the process and keep going until you
find a step where you actually get a
decrease or satisfy some some criterion
so the traditional criterion is you want
the actual decrease of the function
obtains to be a small multiple of the
decrease that the first order Taylor
series promised to give you like 1% of
what the first order Taylor series
promised here we actually follow these
authors who use a slightly different
criterion I actually had a paper in 2010
it also used a cubic criterion but they
just say that we'll take the step
provided the amount of decrease we get
as is is at least 8 over 8 is some
number less than 1 times that alpha Q
who alphas the step length times the
cube of D the step that's good enough if
we get that much decrease we're
guaranteed to be able to prove
complexity results so what's the purpose
of this well the purpose is that you're
going to be able to show that the amount
of decrease here is substantial enough
that you can parlay it into an overall
complexity result and that's what that's
what we'll do later on do you think
regularization I've already mentioned
that earlier on yep you just changed the
acceptance criteria yeah no we do
backtracking but we use this as the
acceptance criteria yes yeah okay cubic
organization I've already mentioned this
is where you look for some cubic upper
bound on f of XK plus D in this case if
M K is greater than the Hessian
Lipschitz constant over 6 this is
guaranteed to be an upper bound on the
function but in the national project
paper they also have ways of choosing
this adaptively in case it doesn't work
you you know if it doesn't work then you
Jack it up by a factor of 2 or something
and try again so you can turn it into
something adaptive now the point here is
if this is really closely related to
trust region if you look at this problem
and this problem this version of the
trust region problem the only difference
is that d squared here is related has
been replaced by d cubed but if i just
defined row K to be M K times D I've got
the same thing so the two things are
really you know almost identical
to within you know just a slightly
different perspective and in fact
several papers written recently by Frank
Curtis and Daniel Robinson and other
people basically reinterpret trust
region methods using the machinery of
the cubic regularization approach and
just say that whatever complexity you
get for cubic regularization if you
tweak your trust region method
appropriately you can get the same sorts
of results and here's another technique
that I think it's quite powerful and
interesting and this it's this judicious
use of random perturbations to get away
from saddle points and this is based on
this paper that that Jason Lee and Ben
and several other people in this room
wrote about 18 months ago which which
asserted that if you're dealing with a
smooth and on convex function and you're
doing a steepest descent method you have
to be incredibly unlucky to terminate at
a saddle point there's really a set of
measure zero for points that actually
will stop at a saddle point and so
building on that observation if you
introduce a little bit of noise into
your gradient calculation this will
basically never happen you'll be able to
guarantee that you can escape from from
that sort of situation and in fact
there's chichen and several other people
including people here worked on an
algorithm earlier this year where they
exploited that property to come up with
an algorithm that just uses gradients no
Hessians to be found anyway here and
when the gradient seems to be flat they
inject a little bit of noise into the
step and then continue taking gradient
steps and then after a while they check
did I decrease the function
significantly or not since I added that
noise if I did decrease its if a
significantly I must have been escaping
from a saddle point if the function
actually hasn't changed that much I must
have been near a local minimum so that's
essentially though the way it works
so this judicious use of noise I think
is a there's a technique that we can
probably apply in a lot of other
interesting context I just want to make
a note that there's a there's a somewhat
different context in constrained
optimization call this watchdog
technique that has a little bit of a
similar flavor there's a problem in
constrained optimization when you're
solving a constrained optimization
problem that you want to sort of do too
you want to decrease the objective
function and you want to get more
feasible then often these two it's hard
to sort of find a way to combine those
two goals into a single merit function
and there are these these sort of nasty
examples where you can get a step that
actually is a very good step that takes
you close to a solution but it does
worse by both of those measures and so
any reasonable optimization method would
reject it so these people came up with
this technique called watchdog a few
years ago which said okay
let's just take this step and then take
a few more steps and after a while let's
see what happened to the feasibility and
the MV and the objective and if I have
to say five steps I've done a good job
at reducing both of them then the
original step must have been okay if I'm
all messed up after five steps then I'll
go back to that original step and change
the sub-problem and make it more
conservative so this reminds me a little
bit of what they're doing here but it's
you know probably the only philosophical
relationship but that's still an
interesting idea okay
so I'm in the part of the talk I'm in
the last 17 minutes where I'm going to
talk about the algorithm that that we
came up with I claim that it's it's more
elementary than the approaches that have
been proposed so far put a little note
here your mileage may vary this of
course is a subjective opinion probably
came from the fact that I stared at it
long enough that it all made sense but
if you look at it you may not agree but
essentially the idea is that we've got a
bunch of different ways of choosing the
search direction which I'll explain but
once we've chosen the search direction
and once we've chosen the initial step
length along that direction what we do
is backtracking and so all the lemons
that we prove to show that you make
significant progress along each of these
directions all the lemons are the same
they just have the traditional
backtracking argument where they say
okay if the first step if your first
guess that step link was accepted you
get a nice chunk of decrease if you had
to backtrack then you don't have to
backtrack too much and you'll still get
a nice chunk of decrease so in all five
of these situations you're guaranteed to
get at least a certain amount of
decrease that you can then parlay into a
complexity result
we can modify this to bolta a fast
convergent phase onto the end of it and
get sort of rapid asymptotic convergence
I'm going to talk about an exact version
of this method we assume that eigen
value calculations and uten steps etc
are all computed exactly at the end I'll
talk about an inexact version okay so
just a reminder of the notation I'll use
DK for the gradient these are these
literatures constants that i've used a
few times I'll use you H for the upper
bound on the Hessian you H and LG are
actually kind of the same thing but for
technical reasons when we're dealing
with e when we're dealing with the in
exact version we sort of prefer to use
the you H and then F below I'd uses the
lower bound on the the overall lower
bound which all asuma's is there on the
objectives okay alright so the next
slide has the five different search
directions but as a prelude to that one
thing that we do is once we calculate
the gradient which we do at every
iteration we calculate the gradient we
look at the curvature along the gradient
direction so I just take the gradient
multiply the hessian on both sides by
the gradient divided by this to
normalize and i look at that quantity
and if that's sufficiently negative
there's no reason for me to go looking
for a negative curvature direction on
the hessian if the gradient is already a
direction of negative curvature there's
no need to do any sort of lanchester
eigenvalue calculation i can just use
that direction so this plays into the
step selection this quantity here so
here are the five the five types of our
steps the first two are just scalings of
the steepest descent direction the last
three Newton type directions or negative
curvature directions okay so the first
two it's basically just minus the minus
the gradient but with different scalings
first of all if the curvature all of the
curvature of the negative gradient along
the negative gradient direction is
pretty small
that means there's not much curvature so
the linear of the linear Taylor series
approximation is actually valid out to
some distance the curvature isn't
contributing very much so that
encourages you to actually take a pretty
long step along the native grade
interact
you scale by one over the gradient to
the to the 1/2 you can bite off a pretty
big chunk of decrease in that case in
the case where the the curvature is
actually going negative so then the
negative gradient direction is actually
really good because not only are you
going downhill with respect to the
gradient
you're also curling downhill with
respect to the Hessian as well and so
you use kick you can use a different
scaling there and you can but by using
the scaling you can provably again get a
certain amount of a certain nice chunk
of improvement ok so if neither of these
things are true then you're in this
regime where you need to look at the
Hessian ok so the first one is the first
thing you do is to do some sort of eigen
value calculation and get some
approximation to this most negative
eigen value and in that case you just
take the same step that I had in my
little toy algorithm back at the start
you just step along the the eigen vector
corresponding the most negative eigen
value ok you do that when the negative
eigen value is less than minus epsilon H
ok what if that's not true what if the
the Hessian is almost positive definite
or maybe strictly positive definite in
the case where it's nicely positive
definite if the minimum eigen value is
bigger than epsilon H then you take a
Newton step and we all know they're good
steps Newton steps are good stuff
ok and this is a good thing to do
because you're close to a region where
things seem to be convex in the case
where the negative eigen vector
the minimum eigen value is between minus
epsilon H and epsilon H then you take
this regularize Newton step you add a
little bit on to the Hessian to boost
the eigen to boost this coefficient
matrix to be positive definite and you
take that step instead ok so these five
types of step all make sort of some kind
of sense in the version of the paper
that you'll find on the archive this is
the convergence guarantee we get we show
that eventually in a certain provable
amount of work you can you you stop at
an iteration K where the minimum of the
current gradient and the next gradient
that you get after taking one more step
where the best of those two is below the
threshold and where the minimum eigen
value is bigger than minus epsilon H so
this is a little bit different from the
crow
Tirion I showed you at the start and
when I gave this talk last weekend chi
Jin actually asked the question well can
you fix this up to you actually get this
kind of guarantee and so I went and
thought about it that night in my
apartment in North Berkeley and figured
out yes you can by just bolting on a
little bit of extra complication onto
our method you can guarantee that you
with the same complexity you can
guarantee that you terminate it this
with this kind of condition other people
use different variants somehow some
people have worked on this get this
guarantee others get some guarantee more
like this including these papers here so
the analysis I'm going to spare you the
the details of the analysis and just cut
pretty much to the final result there
are sort of four technical lemmas in the
end we're able to show that the amount
of decrease you get regardless of which
one of these five kinds of steps that
you talk is is bounded below by Sai
which is a function of these two
convergence tolerances and so is defined
as the minimum of these four quantities
you know this one's epsilon G to the
three over two that's good this is
epsilon H to the three we've seen that
before and the Toei algorithm there's
another one which combines the two
there's another one here which comes
from the regular as a Newton step which
is a slightly more complicated
combination of the two but you can see
that all of them are functions of
epsilon G and epsilon H and just by
using the traditional argument we can
convert that into a complexity that
basically you get as a reciprocal of
this quantity all of the proofs look the
same if you look at the paper we just
say okay given the initial scaling of
the search direction if alpha K is
equals 1 is the if your initial guess at
step length which is 1 in this case is
accepted you get this desired lower
bound holding usually the argument for
that is trivial otherwise you're going
to have to do a certain amount of
backtracking the amount of backtracking
you do you're guaranteed to stop when
you get some lower bound that satisfies
again that satisfies this minimal
decrease argument the number of
backtracking steps you have to do to get
from 1 to that lower bound is a log
function of the lower bound we show that
that's not too big
and you get a different bound for each
of the five steps but in the end you all
of them gives a big enough quantity that
you can you can say that overall it's a
good rate now here's where we start
playing games about how do we choose
epsilon G and epsilon H and how do we
relate them to each other probably the
most sensible thing to do is to set
epsilon G to be some value and set
epsilon H to be the square root of that
value in that way we can we can
essentially make all four of the
quantities in this men expression
roughly the same so if epsilon H squared
is approximately equal epsilon G all
four of these terms are approximately
epsilon G to the three over two and so
we get we can get some sort of unified
complexity bound if you wanted you could
choose the same for both I'm not
completely sure what makes more sense
from a you know a philosophical point of
view whether this one really should be
the square of that one or the other way
around
then of course you get a worse
complexity the complexity is dominated
by this term here it's going to be
smaller than these other terms this is
going to be one this is going to be
epsilon of three over two this is going
to be epsilon cube and so you get a
worse complexity estimate okay in that
case but we still like this one better
and that's also what other people have
tended to make this choice okay now this
is an iteration complexity going back to
this issue of how much work do you have
to do in each iteration you know method
it's somewhat different if you're in the
if you're taking one of the first two
types of step the negative gradient step
you're basically only you have to do one
gradient evaluation and one hashing
vector product if you're going to do a
Newton step you're going to have to
solve a linear system involving the
Hessian so it's a lot more work okay so
if we start counting up the actual
amount of computation you have to do and
get an operation complexity it makes
life a little bit more complicated I
call that you can think you can think in
terms of evaluation complexity that
takes into account the number of
backtracking that you do but let's talk
about operation complexity before we can
really talk about that we have to think
about an inexact version of this method
that is to take account of the fact that
I don't really want to have to calculate
the Newton step exactly I just want to
run it
you quantity of gradient iterations and
come up with some approximation to that
step I really don't want to calculate
the minimum eigenvalue of the hessian
exactly I just want to find a value
that's sort of sufficiently negative has
sufficient negative curvature using LAN
choice okay so we can take that basic
method we can sort of introduce non
smoothness in exactness everywhere
without affecting the complexity at all
I guess I'll skip the details on that
but again you can go back to these
papers on the analysis of randomized LAN
choice and get rigorous rigorous
expressions for the for the complexity
we actually have to do a little a little
bit of tweaking in the case of these
Newton and regularize Newton steps
because the convergence criterion that
we need to satisfy is a little bit more
complicated than good old-fashioned
Newton CG used to do in Newton CG you
basically iterate with the Newton
equations until the residual is less
than some small multiple of the initial
gradient we actually need a slightly
stronger condition that involves the
negative eigen value of the Hessian as
well and this leads to a slightly
different complexity estimate but again
it's related to it still basically order
square root of condition number two
within a long term the extra complexity
only comes into this log term which is a
lot less significant than this term here
so it doesn't change things too much
okay the operation complexity as I said
you just basically take that reciprocal
of that negative decrease amount as I
mentioned earlier there's always a
possibility of failure whenever you do a
LAN choice iterate there's this delta
possibility of failure so you have to
choose Delta small enough that the
aggregate possibility of failure over
all your iterations is still acceptable
fortune fortunately the delta e comes
into the complexity expression for LAN
choice as a log okay so for example a
couple of I had to hide the Delta
appearing here it only comes in under
the log so it doesn't it doesn't mess
you up too much okay so if you take this
iteration complexity and then merge it
in with the amount of work you have to
do at every iteration the most expensive
thing you ever have to do
to run LAN chess or CG and that turns
out to because of the the conditioning
of the matrices you're applying that to
is bounded above in fact it's bounded by
PI epsilon H to the cap is bounded by by
epsilon e to the minus 1 the extra
complexity you get is an extra epsilon
to the minus 1/4 so this epsilon the
minus 3 over 2 you have to multiply that
by epsilon to the minus 1/4 and you end
up with this epsilon as minus 7 over 4
and this will be familiar to any of you
that have worked on this the papers that
came out late last year essentially
you've got this this kind of a rate so
we get the same rate okay and here's
where I cross the boundary into
numerical calculations claim on my
postdoc and collaborator on this project
has programmed this up in MATLAB and got
some results on the 56 problems in the
cutest collection only small ones here
we said epsilon Z to tempt to be 10 to
the minus 6 epsilon H should be the
square root of that 10 and minus 3
programmed up a few variants one was the
exact version of the method where we do
exact eigen value calculations exact
solves using CG in those cases just for
to sort of get our apples to apples
roughly apple apples to apples
comparison of the operation counts we
counted these as n matrix vector
multiplies okay then we programmed up a
version where we did approximate
solution the Newton systems but we still
did an exact eigen value calculation and
then we program about the the fully I
should say claim all programmed up the
fully in exact version where you use the
pro randomly started land choice and an
approximate CG and we get this
performance profile now how many of you
know how to read these things good thank
you
not too many maybe I'll give a I'll give
my best guess at a quick summary so here
I'm comparing three methods on 50
problems okay we get a runtime for each
of them if they terminate satisfactorily
we can we can keep track well actually
what we're keeping track of here is the
number of patient vector products or
gradient evaluations that we're doing so
we count up how many of these we needed
to solve the problem and then we compare
for each problem we compare the three
the
the three numbers so for example of this
if this algorithm achieved the best
value on the problem we give it we give
it a score of 1 so what the way to read
this is that that this algorithm the red
one
55% at a time he was the best of the
three on solving these this collection
of 50 50 odd problems we like I think
this is a log base of 2 so this is
saying that 90% of the time it was in it
within a factor of 4 of having the best
operation count so is no more than 4
times worse than the best operation
chance yeah good question
not necessarily yeah I may be finding
different solutions I think in the
majority of the cases they did from
talking to claim walk they usually did
these might have been easy problems so
anyway if you're reading these charts
the ones with the lines closest to the
top of the better algorithms and where
they asked them toed out tells you how
many they ultimately solved so in this
case all of the algorithms ultimately
solved all of the problems because they
all end up hitting one but sometimes
they could take vastly different amounts
of time to do it but this one is was the
best this was the fully inexact one so
you do get some mileage by doing the
eigenvector and Newton step calculations
in exactly you do get significant
improvement in the overall method these
exact methods tended to be a bit slower
so that's it so summarizing there is
renewed interest in smooth methods you
can get complexity results now people
have proposed a lot of sort of
interesting ways to do that and now
we're getting promising numerical
results of course what we ultimately
want to do is to apply these to some of
the problems that I talked about at the
start for example in deep learning where
you're dealing with functions that have
this very specific summation form and so
you're not able to get exact ratings
exact Hessians what what can you do in
that case
and then also extending all of this to
constrain problems there's a bit of a
challenge though I know several of us
are thinking about and that's it so I'd
like to thank myself for the talk and
and thank you for listening very heard a
couple of minutes and we'll we have
maybe one minute for questions
yeah did you try the - - no it's
actually a good question now we should
program that up yeah we can just come up
with an exact version of that yeah that
would be a good thing to try yeah cool
like you know how well can you do yeah
there are some counter examples due to
kata school and want so they they
construct examples where for non-convex
problems where these methods are pretty
much hit these bounds with something
very close to them and I've got this
clever construction technique where they
sort of predefined what the sequence of
iterates is and then they interpolate a
function that sort of hits those idiots
and it's quite a nice technique yeah
maybe one more
but conceptually the smallest eigenvalue
isn't your whole narrative for cg right
yeah some knowledge of a complicated
quantity to compute is there uh-huh yeah
so you're having to do this you're
having to estimate that quantity
currently well I mean the the holy grail
for me is proving that Newton CG
achieves doing Newton CG with complexity
ditching land shots
I mean CG seems to be incredibly good at
finding your place CG to an indefinite
system that almost always just homes in
on the negative curvature directions
right and we spent months trying to
prove that with guaranteed complexity
and we have some limited results but and
we haven't given up on that and so
ultimately what I'd like to show is just
a vanilla Newton CG that's in like
chapter 5 of the book that you can you
know maybe do a couple of extra tests
and show that you get complexity without
having this land choice you know
estimation bolted on and all that stuff
and I think this is pretty close to that
I mean it's sort of Newton CG but it has
this extra land shots calculation in
there that it's one thing that's
different maybe just one more and then
we have to move on to the next chair
yeah
like another shrine is much smaller than
the lucious options their gradient yeah
yeah usually are they adaptive to that
constant usually for them before convex
function for example I could drive the
green here and just agreed in the
descent
yeah I haven't thought about that but
certainly you could do that yeah you
could have adaptive you could have
adaptive like precision levels for how
much how accurately you get negative
direction you could have adaptivity on
the CG calculations for the Newton type
steps yeah good question I don't know
the answer to that yeah I don't know the
answer to that but that's certainly
something worth considering yeah okay
we'd better move on to the next talk oh
okay we have a breakdown okay
[Applause]